I kind of feel like you what you did
with that was like the what Kendrick did
with the control freak or the control
record that was my exact sentiment you
know 100 just wanted to challenge the
game and have some fun and raise some
questions that's never like I never said
[__] was white no I didn't other than
one person yeah yeah you know I mean but
it's like I never set the rest of them
dudes was whack I just was like can do
do this I never seen him do this you
know I mean I like that's that's all it
was putting in con put it in in context
in an artistic way did you and hit make
ever have a combo after your guys's uh
online back and forth nah
I just assumed it was like it was like
nice promotion for everybody right nah
that was great man for sure that was
solid I think I think you hit it on the
head because like uh who did I have oh I
had Eric Ballinger here and we were
talking about like the difference
between you guys yeah like Rick Rubin
doesn't make beats did you like
obviously I mean I feel like I'm sure he
made some of them classes Rick Rubin
says he he doesn't know how to do
anything he's there for his taste
I don't believe that I think that's the
older Rick Rubin I know he was in there
cooking something which I don't know he
said that he he doesn't make any beats
he's there for his taste and I feel like
I mean that's like kind of the lane hit
makers and it's like you bring him again
because he's got an ear he's got the
writers and then you you got it all you
could take the NPC out and you could you
know there's nothing you can't touch you
know what I'm saying we're gonna leave
it at that yeah
Jesus I just saw did in Paris just have
a new certification yeah just went
diamond yeah crazy and it's crazy
because you know that was like a few
years before the stream in there so that
was like people really buying that song
that's that's like the difference in the
game now like I just feel like
it was like a little more earned back in
the day like I just seen I spice how
long she's been out less than a year she
got a billion streets like I'm like I
spices I gave us it a wild place I'll be
like I think she's out streaming like
almost everybody except like Bad Bunny
and Drake maybe that's guys that's
incredible you know whatever she did in
her life to get that blessing for sure
but you know just music Wise It's like
wow this is the era we in you know you
gotta accept it I guess I remember at
your old house in your studio you had
like um you had the Grammy and then you
had there was like a Michael Jordan
photo or something and then there was
like um the canvas of like when Jay and
Kanye
I think they were doing it in Paris
today that was that was right there it
was a parent it was a picture in Paris
yeah
um it's crazy to think like how much
that record like kind of changes your
trajectory of like just hit boy like I
remember during that time there was like
you were you were like one of the young
producers around good music My Guy
lifted from Phoenix and did Mercy
um and I remember he was just telling me
all these stories about like being in
hotel rooms like back to back to back
with like yourself everybody
everybody's good enough like what's like
one of the craziest like uh stories you
could tell about like just those days
like working with gay working with the
good guys it's a lot man definitely like
that uh trip I'm sure lifted is talking
about we all went to London one time and
everybody was there Sean pushing Two
Chains you know obviously yay just being
locked in I remember it was so crowded
in uh one of the hotel rooms and
everybody came in because they was
working on it was either click or Mercy
wanted two and like Sean was sitting on
the floor with a mic like this like
recording a hook for one of them joints
and I just I'll never forget that Craig
a was right here change was in everybody
was in there just a room full of people
and they just was getting it done by any
means like right there